[Music]  in this video we'll show you how to  predict prices using a machine learning  model from google sheets find nasdaq  composite index price historical data  and download it open the sheet import  the data and create a chart  open script editor  go to ml integration samples at github  and copy the code  go back to script editor paste the code  add bigquery api service  deploy the code  in the sheet specify gcp project id  select date and open columns train the  model  add 900 rows and select them to forecast  the price movement for the next 900 days  select forecast to render the price  prediction  that's it to learn more about the ml  integration sample code look at the  links in the video description  [Music]  you